si parte siamo tornati ragazzi con harry
stickman mancava flynn the complex anche
tra le cose che dovevo riportare gli
aerei stig manfrine comp
per chi non lo conoscesse playing the
complex sarebbe l'infiltrazione nel
complesso flame vuol dire infiltrazione
rosso lei mi ricordo più niente neanche
se un'infiltrazione se ci devo scappare
va beh lo vediamo oggi feels good to be
back to this game trade and complex va
bene tra l'altro in uno mai capito
esattamente qual è la cronologicamente
la direzione che dovrei prendere nel
giocare in tutti gli episodi criminosi
ma perché questo si trova sempre
imprigionato da qualche parte non ho
capito come ci finisce cioè ha detto e
io devo tradurre in prima persona ci
sono un sacco di criminali più famosi
del mondo rinchiusi qua più pericolosi
travi di henry sti clan ma posso già
fare le cose va bene allora busta a
busta vuol dire che la spingo sopra va
bene proviamo una botola e la madonna
sono le prigioni di massima sicurezza
ragazzi incredibile da che parte la tiro
su tiro sulla zia esatte sono bravissimo
ha detto synchronized takedown tolga
ibra tolga esattamente lasciarmi non
vedo come essere più alto dovrebbe
aiutarti queste reti effettivamente ci
hai anche ragione bounce bros non è
andato benissimo
riprendiamo aveva la prima lo azzeccata
subito incredibile di stress
e vabbè vai via
però ma fai qualcosa ma la mappa
esattamente che cos'è a sono i bivi che
vuoi prendere va bene se manca
synchronized takedown che era il più
intelligente da fare già subito
effettivamente vuoi spingermi di sopra
perché così io posso entrare aprire la
porta va bene allora siamo il gra vitor
2.0 tra tutti questi oggetti come fanno
ad averli nostro sempre chiesto niente
de force
e vabbè hai scoperto adesso di averla io
sono entrato veramente così vi sono
scappati tutti abbiamo fatto sorry
granata posso usare anche in cui in
combo granata e taser forse no forse
troppo granata e cross bot
[Musica]
chiusa la bellissima voce di farle la
bellissima e bellissima perché se si
ferma prima dell'esplosione è bellissimo
film the complex fosse il più bello
non so se il più bello ma uno dei più
belli stai per iphone cras bar o fatto
un trick shot le zidane istant replay
voglio un miliardo di mi piace
vi prego
e va beh noi ragazzi fermi fermi questo
è il più bel momento di tutta la
collezione di harry stickman questo è il
più è quello fatto meglio
vabbè dai per iphone e taser
spero siano stati bravi ce l'ho anch'io
quello di ok siamo tutti attrezzati qua
athos lancia il cappello dei ris compiti
ha funzionato subito solo fortissimo e
ho fatto casino radio liberato tutti non
volevo liberare tutti che non era il mio
metti farc ha preso il ginocchio
[Applauso]
ammazza che ginocchio ciò ha vinto
tralascia per tex make up ace 4 finta di
[Applauso]
ci siamo ragazzi dobbiamo trovare il
modo giusto per uscire per scappare il
camion di qua o assegna la sinistra a
sinistra non è giusto andiamo a destra
allora con la moto ma no ma [ __ ] la
moto ha preso a cuore questa cosa mi sa
che don credo anche quello e make a
facebook che donna incredibile mi sono
trovato oggi mag abbiamo visto è stato
bellissimo allora vorrei provare a fare
un paio di altre cose visto che è pieno
di roba da fare
ho fatto un sacco di vivi vorrei provare
di nuovo il primo tipo all'inizio c'era
c'è richard takle teca non so parla
potevo fuggire giorno la tona e la
prigione sovietica spiccio auspicio sono
sony contro il muro dei too fast furious
acrobatic
eventi item ma no non ci credo
stan parte non l'avevo mai fatta mi sa
ho preso il fantasma davvero era quello
giusto ragazzo azzeccando tutto com'è
possibile solo io sono scappato tra
l'altro come possibile la tipa l'ho
lasciata la maison sbattuto sono proprio
un uomo di qua
esatto questa cosa gli sta partendo nome
[Musica]
ecco questa è la seconda parte più bella
di tutto dal rischi bynight sic menani
avanti devo combattere sul serio come
possono fortissimo seguit track costume
sandwich non vedo perché non seguì ci
possa aiutarmi
li vorrei anche io sì semplice però non
so dove si trova a madonna come ti sei
difendere fratello track sono scappato
non sono scappato scherzavo aiuto ciò
devo essere velocissimo rispondere
niente sono diciamo slam effetto non
facciamo solo assistono preview per un
niente tra l'altro coward star come dove
lo trovate 9 no ma no sono tornati in
prigione però airbag non era l'airbag
devo stare attento e premere la cosa
giusta quando esce render ragazzi
difficilissimo cosa devo fare alla fine
ha forse non faccio niente non tocco
niente se non tocco niente se come
succede qualcosa non so cosa sono ancora
vivo come solo stare zitto
presumibilmente morto
va bene ci sono tante o sono stato bravo
alla fine sono un miliardo di robe che
non avevo visto fighissimo ce n'è ancora
una mi sa che play fingiti morto ottima
tattica e mettilo insieme agli altri ma
no niente wait for transfer di cui posso
fuggire
c'è questa è l'ultima possibilità per
finire il gioco allora influenza finta
cookie
beh però che figo ciò che alla finestra
ci avevo la finestra laser flame
ma dove li trova sti oggetti
a posto beh tra i due scegliere le
cuffie governance ce lo sta dicendo come
se tipo si passava a prendere kenya
mangia una pizza
non credevo provare solo ad uscire lui
mi recupera con l'elicottero va bene
babouche in dirt del flash flash
forse avevo fatto questa anni fa naimi
helicopter charles snipe
secondo me ha preso me lo sapevo e mini
helicopter c'è un elicotterino piccolo
uscito l'elicottero gigante vabbè butta
giù lanciarazzi effetto effetto cori
perfetto
l'air france è stato bellissimo era
bellissimo molto più efficace come non
l'avevo mai finito tutto mai per i
ragazzi che starà friends and complex
c'era un sacco di cose potevi fare
fighissime ente manca solo stealing the
diamond che faremo quindi ragazzi
proprio video ci è piaciuto è sempre ed
è affidata a rivedere gli episodi di
arresti quando mi piace un sacco non mi
ricordo niente
ed è proprio per questo che figo se
invece dovesse lasciare un commento mi
piace anche affari sociali che come
aiutato da notizia la si scrive noi ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo video da ragazzo
[Musica]